[Music]
luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and it is a beautifully sunny
day here in the alaskan bush
it's about 25 degrees fahrenheit so it
is just absolutely perfect weather and a
gorgeous day
to do some bushcraft and survival
camping
look at these fox tracks right here
got this fresh gift of snow here from
last night and look at it
there's probably three sets of tracks
right on here
oh it's so nice to get out and about on
sunny days like this but it comes with
its own set of problems
you can actually go snow blind out here
it's so sunny and there's so much snow
so you get two or three nice days in a
row you'll get sunburned on your
eyeballs
hurts like the devil oh
there's a little red squirrel right
there
could have shot the guy but man i've
eaten them before they're not very good
alaskan squirrels are not like the ones
down the lower 48 they're scrawny and
stringy and
don't taste very good
we must be near a frozen river look at
the size of these cottonwood trees you
only get big cottonwood trees near water
oh here's the river yeah see all the
snow machine tracks
these frozen rivers become our highways
in the wintertime
i'm gonna walk along this river a little
bit
i might find a little log jam would give
me a lot of firewood
i might find a gravel bar to build my
shelter
maybe some open water so i got nice easy
water sources
but look at that view huh
yeah alaska does not disappoint
we'll take it out
this dark dry exposed rock on the side
of the riverbank
so much warmer than just a few feet over
there in the snow bank it's early
morning but still
just that little bit of sunlight we've
gotten so far has warmed this up a lot
by the end of the day this is going to
be really really pleasant i'd really
like to find a flat dry spot to build a
shelter for tonight but i wanted to be
near some dead wood so i don't have to
hike forever to get my firewood and
materials for my shelter
check this out
see all of this
see every one of these willow trees has
the bark stripped off it this inner
layer of the bark of the willow tree is
edible and it's one of the only food
sources you can find here in the
wintertime so all the animals that don't
hibernate or migrate out they eat these
willow trees and this is all done by
moose you can see how high up the tree
it is but this is what the snowshoe
hares eat as well when you get a big
patch of willows like this you're gonna
find moose and you're gonna find
snowshoe hair and you're gonna find the
predators that feed off of
the inner bark of these will trees also
contains aspirin especially if you get a
nice green shoot you scrape off all that
green bitter inner bark you can suck on
it if you have a headache and it's
supposed to help a little bit it takes a
lot of willow bark to equal one aspirin
tablet so you gotta hear some moderately
old moose prints
big pile of moose poop if you ask most
alaskans which animal they're most
afraid of it's not the bears it's the
moose they can be so nasty and they're
just massive animals and they don't mind
being really close to humans
grizzly bears usually just run away as
soon as they smell or hear you
moose will sit there and pick a fight
with you
yeah let's check it out we got some dead
wood here
might be able to do something with this
i'll tell you what this might not be a
bad place to sleep for the night it's
got a flat sandy bit right there
got some water some dead wood
we're obviously way too close to the
river to build a permanent structure but
i think this might be perfect for just a
night or two looks pretty nice i'm gonna
drop my pack and explore a little bit
oh
now that's a big fresh moose print right
there
yeah
you know shotguns are a great survival
gun because they're so versatile you can
use them for different things depending
on which bullets you use
this is a number six shot two three
quarter inch bullet great for rabbits
and small birds and squirrels
this is a three inch one ounce slug
you from grizzly bears moose you can use
it to kill deer
just gonna throw that in here since
we're seeing all this moose sign just in
case
in a few months this spot i'm walking is
going to be under about four or five
feet of water and this is going to be a
fast moving 30 foot wide river when the
water all freezes a lot of these rivers
dry right up
plenty of fuel
there's some good dead trees right there
as well
tell you what it's so nice to not need
my snowshoes
clear days like this the temperature
fluctuations get huge
it's really beautiful in the daytime
gets bitterly cold in the night
so i got to make sure i build a good
shelter while the weather's nice
some more moose prints see how deep they
are moves are like 2 000 pounds so when
they step in the snow they sink right to
the bottom it makes it so hard for them
to walk in this deep snow they really
like walking along those river banks
because it's just so much less energy
there's so many willows around it's a
really good chance moose will come
wandering up the riverbank at night
check it out we're starting to get [ __ ]
willow buds on the willow trees
oh the snow's starting to thaw out
oh
snow is starting to thaw out and i'm
starting to sink a little bit
let's get out of the sun
oh
so you stand on the stuff that's in the
shadows it's solid
stand on the snow in the sunlight
you sink
stuck the barrel of my gun in the snow
what's nice about a brake action you can
clear it out so easy
nice little trail snack this is a
cornish pasty traditional pastry in
southwest england they're a great trail
snack because you can eat them cold and
with dirty hands
this is like a pork and raisin one a
little non-traditional
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
uh
come check this out
that is the first butterfly of the year
uh
this is anata it's a traditional
japanese hatchet i bought it in kyoto in
2018 when we did our world tour video
um
oh
oh
it's like a greenhouse underneath this
tarp
it is so warm in here man it feels so
good and warm here on this gravel bar i
can't even begin to describe it here i
need to bust out my thermometer and show
you guys so i've got two thermometers
and you can see right here the ambient
air temperature is about 34 degrees
fahrenheit so just slightly above
freezing but i put another thermometer
here in the sunlight over here on the
rocks check this out
look at this
on the gravel bar
it is 80 degrees 80 degrees fahrenheit
there's a 46 degree difference between
the temperature of the air and the
temperature of this riverbank that is
massive i'll tell you what it feels
pretty amazing on this riverbank right
now but all that's going to change
tonight when the sun sets it's supposed
to get down to about 14 degrees
fahrenheit so we need to store as much
of this heat as we can and store it in
our shelter i'm going to show you how to
do that really easy
[Music]
all right we need to get a fire started
i'm going to do it with a piece of steel
and a flint rock here got my char cloth
to catch the spark and turn it into an
ember i've got some shredded up jute to
turn that ember into a flame
so i'm going to do is i'm going to build
up a nice big bonfire right there where
i'm going to sleep
it's going to heat up the ground store a
lot of energy down in the rocks it's
also going to dry out the ground and
it's gonna make it really warm inside
the shelter plus i'm gonna boil some
water to drink because i forgot to bring
any
i leaned over and put that pot on the
fire the gust of wind blew the flames up
in my face there i think i burned some
of my bangs
smells like it
well i got a nice fire going and plenty
of room to burn it
i'm going to throw whole logs on there
and let the fire cut my logs up for me
save me some energy
that's good water
this is one of the prettiest spots i've
camped in a long time
the lovely weather
that's burning pretty good
some people will tell you that if you
use river rocks for your campfire ring
the rocks will explode
we're gonna put that to the test today
aren't we
there we go just move the fire over a
little bit buried the coals with a
little bit of dry sand
and we're going to have a really hot
foundation to put our shelter on top of
if you guys want to see more about this
trick i did a video where i slept out in
the snow with only a wool blanket using
this trick
so
[Music]
thank
uh
well looks like the sun's about to
disappear over the mountains
i've got a nice pile of firewood over by
the fire
just need to get a big pile of tinder so
i can start my fire in the morning
without having to go look for firewood
but i think after that we're ready to
get some dinner and i'm hungry
the only thing worse than having to get
out of your bed in the morning is having
to get out of your bed and go look for
firewood in the morning
alaska has the best tasting water i
swear
[Music]
all right i think it's time to go start
dinner and i need a steak stick
well i have brought a ton of food for
dinner i've got a massive seasoned steak
got a sweet potato with marshmallows
brown sugar and butter and cinnamon and
it's all wrapped up in tin foil
and i've got a bunch of bread dough here
and i've got some honey butter
[Music]
got some honey butter here
i'll loosen the lid a little bit and
just sit it by the fire like so
[Applause]
uh
all righty
um
well that is good
all right
ah seasoned meat honey butter fresh
bread
these are good things
oh
that was pretty good i think i might
need another piece of bread
there we go that's looking good
there you go campfire version of sweet
potato casserole with the melted
marshmallows and butter and cinnamon
it's fabulous just gotta let this cool
down
oh
well that's nice
bread steak and potatoes
i think i need to wash my hands
it's my japanese hunting knife it was a
gift from a friend when i was in kyushu
there's a real shark skin on the handle
it's like sandpaper
excellent grip love this knife
tell you what guys it is warm in here my
legs are cooking
this sand is just hot with the coals
underneath it and i've got the heat of
the fire
and then it's just not that cold out
here because i'm sitting on this baked
sand bar
it's just absolutely great
ah i can't believe how light it is it's
8 30 and i can still see outside
just changes so quick this time of year
two months ago sun was setting at four
o'clock
in a couple months the sun's going to be
setting at 11 o'clock
oh my goodness
i am tired
my socks are dry i'm full i'm warm i'm
just going to go ahead and get my
sleeping bag here
it's been a really nice day
oh i'll tell you what guys i think i
might be getting a little bit of a cold
my nose is stuffy my throat's scratchy
and i'm just really really tired
i think i'm just gonna hang out here and
watch the fire just relax a little bit
well guys it's gotten late and properly
cold but it is really warm in here
between the heat coming up through the
ground and the fire and the
heat reflector stone wall i made i mean
it's just it's really cozy in here and i
was originally planning on
on sealing this up on both sides like a
little tent and then just pulling the
hot rocks inside to warm things up but
it's i don't think it's going to be
necessary so i'm just going to go to bed
and i'm going to run a little time lapse
and i'll see you guys
[Music]
up
[Music]
uh
tell you what i slept really warm last
night
the air is pretty darn cold but
the ground is it's just not bad the
coals i buried have really gone out
but it still it's just not that cold
it's like
a 40 degree ground instead of a 14
degree ground
the rocks just hold the heat really well
and just getting a thought out warm spot
to set up a shelter makes all the
difference in the world i never pulled
down the side of my tarp and the fire
went out and i was just
really good last night it was it was
really nice
i'll tell you what though i am
definitely sick
my throat hurts so bad and i'm so stuffy
and
i'm really tired
i need a sick day
i don't feel good
i'm gonna make some breakfast so i don't
have much of an
appetite and
we're just going to try to build up some
strength for the hike home
uh
oh looks like we got a snowstorm coming
in
oh
fried smoked pork jowls wrapped in bread
smothered in honey butter
i could eat that every day oh that's so
good
yeah i better pack up my sleeping bag i
don't want to get snow on it
[Music]
[Applause]
that fierce little cold bit of a hike
ahead of me
i'm gonna have some herbal tea
well i used river rocks around my
campfire and i lived to tell the tale
none of them exploded
certain rocks will pop or explode if you
put them in a fire but it has more to do
with what the stone is made out of and
less about whether you pulled them out
of a river or or whatever
all right
uh
oh there we go that was a good campsite
one of the warmest winter shelters i've
ever slept in
i got a lot of hiking to do and not a
lot of energy to do it with so
i better get going
uh without the sunshine that open water
is freezing up
one thing that can get you stranded in
the springtime
is you go hiking in the morning when the
snow is hard and it's really easy to
walk
and then by the afternoon the snow
softens up and you start sinking down in
it
and then you can't get back
you hike out in the morning
hike back in the morning
i think those are some fresh coyote
tracks
since this morning
well i'm gonna go home and take large
quantities of cold medicine
and get some rest and hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you guys want to
see more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel make sure to click
subscribe because we put out new videos
every saturday morning and check out
some of our playlists for more camping
and survival videos i'll put links in
the video description to that below
thanks for watching guys i'll see you
next saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching